good afternoon everyone it's good to be
back I was off doing something that was
so don't ask me please
thanks anyway let's get on to today's
lesson this is a long one folks you may
or may not have heard of this skip but
today we're gonna be learning about SCP
93 object class Euclid special
containment procedures C testing
document SCP 93 t14 outline of testing
conditions as CP 93 must remain on a
mirror at all times and under video
surveillance admittance into the area of
SCP 93 s containment must be authorized
only with proper video recording and
subject retrieval procedures in place
any attempt to use SCP 93 outside of an
approved test will be dealt with
severely up to and including termination
description SCP 93 is a primarily read
disk car from a stone composite
resembling cinnabar with circular
engravings an unknown symbols carved at
0.5 centimeters depth around the entire
object deeper cuts are present on SCP 93
with a depth of one to one and a half
centimeters SCP 93 is 7.62 centimeters
in diameter and fits comfortably into
most palms without abrasion SCP 93 will
change hue when held by a living
individual the colors taken by a CP 93
are still being researched to establish
a link current beliefs all that the
changes depend upon regrets carried by
the holder if SCP 93 is removed from a
mirror and not held by a person it will
seek out the nearest mirror-like surface
SCP 93 has been observed to travel in
the largest possible circle while
rolling building up phenomenal speed the
mechanism of this acceleration is
currently unknown if an obstacle is
between SCP 93 and the nearest
mirror-like surface it will use this
momentum to punch through the obstacle
and continue on its course at this
it will only stop when a mirror-like
surface is contacted despite tremendous
impact velocities no damage will be
dealt to SCP 93 or the mirror additional
notes no records exist to clarify the
nature of SCP 93 s discovery or presence
in the foundation see SCP 93 OD since no
records exist explaining SCP 93 s method
of containment a test procedure was
initiated to establish why Amira's must
be used to contain it the results of SCP
93 t one led to the discovery of living
beings holding SCP 93 being able to move
through mirrors in the series of tests
in SCP 93 T two to ascertain the
destination reached through this travel
now what I just read was revised the
original documentation is as follows SCP
93 object class Euclid special
containment procedures item SCP 93 is to
be kept on a silver mined mirror on a
0.3 by 0.23 meter pedestal at least one
point 22 meters off the ground in
containment cell block object is not to
be contained in areas exceeding three
point six six by three point zero five
meters nor placed on mahogany pine
cherry or aluminum pedestals above or
below level one of containment cell
blocks object can be handled safely
albeit gently without consequences tests
and consequences thereof involving
containment conditions can be viewed in
Section B thirty five one of the
attached report
description object was found on the
shore of the Red Sea 30th of January
1968 admitting a low sigh and a dim blue
glean its color has since turned into an
orange mix of red only emitting a hum of
varying volume whilst in the presence of
female examiner's of ages between 34 and
41 SCP 93 resembled the documented blue
for 54 minutes 34 seconds at 123 on the
26th of April 1986 coincidentally when
the body of one 94 98 3 4 was discovered
in a research facility times between 1 9
4 9 8 34 and SCP 93 remain inconclusive
and effects of prolonged exposure to 93
remain unknown except for in frequent
reports of periods of calmness and in
the case of 242 double 0 for 9 as
periodic waves of depression loss of
balance and thoughts of suicide these
feelings have reportedly not exceeded 11
days in duration objects seem to react
to the presence of 2 4 2 double 0 5 6 by
turning light violet for no more than 2
minutes 9 seconds as documented on the
12th of March 1993
Effects of this reaction remain unknown
additional notes origins of 93 remain
unknown and documents of recovery of 93
have since been destroyed in a fire and
research facility 9th of December 1989
reports on the feelings of researchers
who handled 93 have remained
inconsequential since the 19th of April
1995 okay moving on to SCP 93 t-one
containment test testing of SCP 93
against conditions set forth for
existing containment procedures to
assess viability of continuing such
containment beginning with changing the
type of mirror used as a position of
rest mirrored surface brass frame retail
grade mirror SCP 93 rests without
activity when placed on the mirror this
test alone removes the need for costly
silver or wooden containment systems
standard grade table ASAP 93 turns
upright and begins to roll across the
table surface in one direction making a
u-turn and rolling to the other
completing an oval shape and repeating
this action until a mirror is brought
into its vicinity at which time SCP 93
rolls toward the mirror and lays flat
ways against it sliding towards the
center it is noted that despite the
grainy feel of SCP 93 it does not mark
the mirror in any fashion while moving
across it two mirrors at either end of a
standard grade table SCP 93 gravitates
toward the closer mirror regardless of
orientation and makes no distinction
between different types of mirrors
favoring a factor of distance above all
else in choosing the mirror to move to a
mirror held by a person and moved around
as CP 93 follows the mirror as it moves
gaining speed until a maximum velocity
is reached at any velocity the impact of
SCP 93 against a merit surface results
in no damage to either object a person
holding SCP 93 placing it on a mirror
this test was accidental the result of
one of the staff tripping the other
after some debate about who would be
covering the lunch tab as a result of
the behavior of the researchers it was
discovered that a person holding SCP 93
and placing it against a mirror will in
fact move into the mirror
addendum containment testing
discontinued after establishing that SCP
93 requires only a mirror to rest inert
testing on human interaction with
mirrors while holding SCP 93 authorized
by doctor
[Music]
SCV 93 t2 mirror test testing protocols
subjects testing SCP 93 must wear a
class three buckle harness strapped to
the chest and attached to a tension
pulley system allowing for 300 metres of
movement additional spools may be added
to extend movement if necessary the
clasps connecting these spools must be
high-grade and capable of withstanding
applied force of 0.2 tonnes a field kit
containing the following should be
standard-issue for testing of SCP 93 one
wrist mounted light source with three
hours lifespan and additional power
sources providing up to six additional
hours for zero point five liter water
bottles with water for MREs of any type
plus two plain granola bars chocolate
chips allowed one standard-issue beretta
nine millimeter firearm with 24 rounds
of ammunition loaded this is not to be
issued until subject is passed into a
mirror using SCP 93 and should be given
under armed supervision ensuring that
the subject passes through entirely this
item is to be requisitioned first upon
subjects return and subject to be made
aware of this before leaving a line of
sight within SCP 93's mirror and finally
one standard-issue field knife the
subject is not to be made aware of this
item and must find it on his own within
the kit
the subject must also be attached to a
video system with a camera mounted on
the subjects head or shoulders the video
device should be cable based and allow
for the same length of travel as the
return system wireless cameras have
shown mixed results and should only be
used in testing conditions where SCP 93
is a currently known color new colors
must be tested using a wired feed during
testing the color of SCP 93 must be
recorded as well as history of the
subject in terms of their incarceration
to identify how SCP 93 determines the
color to assume a link appears to be
connected to guilt or lack thereof in
the subjects psyche the attached test
results should be read in order okay I
will now go through mirror test one two
five
buckle up people if you have any coffee
to get now is the time to get it
we good okay mirror test one color blue
subject is d2 of 3/8 for male 34 years
of age strong physique subjects
background shows instance of murder and
attempted suicide subject is cooperative
in all steps of testing subject entered
the provided mirror while holding SCP 93
which emitted a blue color outside
technicians observed that the mirror
retained a true reflection until subject
had completely passed into it at which
time the view changed to an outdoor
landscape heavily tinged in blue video
feed follows an attached medium
obviously you're not going to see the
video feed I will be describing camera
activates flickers into view subject is
looking out over the same field reported
by technicians looks like typical loan
lenders no discernable landmarks visible
as subject pans view left to right only
grass weeds and a breeze moving the
taller grass no trees no living beings
visible subject moves forward as
instructed traveling for approximately
500 steps before something becomes
visible a patch of land up ahead is
barren and grass can be seen dying as
the subject approaches it approximately
300 steps forward subject is standing
before a hole in the ground the hole has
been dug using unknown tools of
primitive origin pulley system engaged
and the camera suffers a light shutter
subject is instructed to enter the hole
after a mile protesting agrees to do so
there was no apparent method of descent
such as ladder or rope subject relies
entirely on his own hands
and the pulley system to slow the
descent approximately 100 meters of
cable is used before a bottom is reached
light source provided in field kit
activated 50 meters down when outside
sources become unreliable sweeping
gestures of light reveal nothing more
than dirt even at the bottom of the hole
subject moves forward with assistance of
light source asked about the blue tinge
subject expresses confusion and says
there is no such tange from his
perspective and there was light is
visible down the passage in 150 meters
of cable has been used out of the
cameras eye sound is recorded of the
firearm being prepared when questioned
about these actions subject States
justified precaution and moves forward
the tunnel turns from bared dirt to a
concrete enclosure subject complains of
a stench the light source is revealed to
be ceiling light fixtures a series of
which with less than a quarter broken
while all others function a series of
six doors three two aside span before
the camera view with a seventh door
visible at the end of the corridor that
has been blocked by what looks like
generic metal shelving debris debris
shows sign of rusting and his typical of
retail store units suggesting other
human presences subject requested to try
doors in whatever order he chooses
subject tries first door on right door
is locked
does not open second door tries to open
but does not budge unlocked but blocked
by something closing second or third
doors tried same results is first going
up the other side the third door does
open fully and light is bright in the
room portable light switch off at this
time as subject pans camera to inspect
the room room is bare no contents but
walls are filthy subject states material
on walls is in dirt but he can
identify it seems to resemble melted
plastic but is brown in color
rather than black door is closed second
door on left has no handle does not move
when pushed the hole where the handle
was is plugged by an unknown material
all doors are shaped in such a way that
nothing can visibly escape from the
sides and space for movement is too thin
to look through even at ground level
first door on the left hand is locked
but part of the key is present and
locked from stem to the ridges back has
been broken off with effort subject
manipulates key to open door and
immediately begins coughing complaining
of a stench walls of room are clean as
his floor ceiling is coated in the same
strange brown material as the third room
in this room there is a makeshift cot
made from aged blankets with a pillow a
wooden crate containing open boxes of
what appear to have been foodstuffs
language appears on video as squiggles
however subject states that they simply
read cereal a second crate in the room
contains what appeared to be empty water
bottles that have dried out
a book lays next to the cop closed no
title or identifying marks on the wall
is what appears to be clipped articles
but language cannot be read subject
asked to remove clippings for retrieval
all articles but one crumble at the
touch due to age the intact article is
put in a field sample container and
seems to be most recent compared to
others asked to investigate the book
subject begins to move toward it audio
on the tape goes strange and a
high-pitched screeching noise like
grinding metal dominates all
communication for about three and a half
seconds subject has not touched the book
still and when the noise stops subject
asks control to repeat request control
made no requests during that time his
headsets were removed subject advise to
leave the room and notes that the door
has begun closing slowly on its own and
if left alone will close subject advised
to leave door alone and to investigate
the door on the right
careful review of the following 10
seconds of tape shows that as the camera
pans a figure is visible at the end of
the tunnel where the seventh door is the
door is open only for a face to be seen
through a crack just before the door
silently closes no details can be seen
subject investigates the second door on
the right
with no mention of anything seen out of
the ordinary this door when pushed
against moves after repeated bashings
moves enough to view inside an angle a
corkboard is visible with more articles
attached to it the top of the box of
cereal can be seen on the floor and what
appears to be a hand lay palm up subject
closes door and pants camera past door 7
which remains closed
seeing nowhere else to explore subject
requested to return subject poses no
protest and complains of ever-increasing
stench as subject returns back down
his camera feed does not change or show
anomaly but control reports a sudden
surge in cable movement pulling an
additional 100 meters of cable through
before going slack again and then
tightening video feed shows subject
ascending tunnels slowly while control
attempts to verify integrity of the
pulley system subject requested to stava
sent but states he is not climbing the
Rope is pulling him up panic sets in on
both sides and subject informed - ready
firearm upon reaching top of hole
nothing is visible on camera and subject
reports nothing has changed in the
landscape then begins a return trip
following the path of the cable
traveling for approximately 900 steps
subject asks how much cable he is used
control admits they are unsure due to
complications but subject traveled in a
straight line to reach the hole so it
should be a straight line back subject
becomes concerned when he states that
more cable is visible now moving in a 90
degree angle away from a point in the
ground subject pans camera around full
circles slowly on film behind subject a
crowd of 37 countable figures stand
silently features are unidentifiable and
they are lacking the blue tinge that
dominates the landscape panic breaks in
control again
but the subject knows only oddity as
being the cable having an angled path
subject tugs his end of the cable it is
taut and does not move control begins to
reel in the pulley system and slack
rapidly whines watching the angle cable
movement can be seen as grass is
disturbed further down the angled
portion from the reeling in then the
line vibrates as it meets resistance and
emits a twang from the recoil subjects
camera pans back along the length of the
cable which now appears to be slowly
allowing more slack before suddenly all
slack is returned and pulley system
begins again control requests subject
returned following cable path screens
are caught on the audio
panic from the subject five shots fired
as subject aims pistol it's something
not visible on camera control reports
being able to see subject returning
toward a point of origin while camera
shows why are disappearing into a
floating point in the air as subject
passes this point all cable is now in
the pulley system and camera films only
the door control reports that the mirror
took approximately five seconds to
return to a reflection and SCP 93
remained blue in color until one hour
after being recovered from the subject a
vial smelling fluid was present on the
subjects clothes around his hands when
the firearm was recovered his fluid
dried quickly and was deemed
insignificant of study due to a lack of
quality sample control personnel
monitoring the mirror state having seen
a massive human being crawling on the
ground easily fifty times the size of a
normal person with no facial features
and a very short arm reach pulling
itself towards the mirror before it
returned to a reflection due to
proximity fine details could not be made
out but at least one observer noted the
being appeared to have been shot from
the marks and the otherwise smooth
featureless face field test kit
recovered from subject containing a
newspaper article that read and was
filed as items ok this is mirror test -
color green subject is d5 double four
nine three female 23 years of age
average physique subjects background
shows instance of grand theft auto and
second-degree murder of two children
during escape with vehicle subject is
cooperative in all steps of testing
subject entered the provided mirror
while holding a CP 93 which had emitted
a green color outside technicians
observed that the mirror retained a true
reflection until subject had completely
passed into it
which time have you changed to a farming
landscape heavily tinged in green
similar to the first test video feed
follows an attached media and again you
will not be seeing anything I will be
describing it camera activates flickers
to view subject is looking out over the
same farmland reported by technicians
all greens through the video feed are
deeper and green tinge overlays the
normal colors of objects similar to the
blue tinge in test one no landmarks from
test one are discernible as subject
pants camera over the area present is a
field long abandoned in the middle of
which stands the remains of a scarecrow
of unknown design fragments left are
rotted and torn nothing grows in the
tilled land a farmhouse is visible to
the right of the field large two stories
a basement shelter entrance is visible
at one end subject prepares her sign
armed immediately and is asked by
control to relax before proceeding her
heavy breathing dominating the audio
feed subject takes a few minutes and
announces that she is fine and then
proceeds as directed to walk the
perimeter of the farmhouse children's
bicycles to a boy and a girls lay
against the house near the shelter doors
one of the doors to the shelter lay in
the grass torn from the entrance has
evidence by splintering wood on the
stairs lay clothes arranged in a
descending order
she used to shirt going down them
belonging to a boy subject begins
screaming at control asking if this is
some sort of sick joke
control assures her that they have never
seen this environment either and to
please calm down
subject takes several minutes to regain
herself before continuing it is unknown
if SCP 93 is linking the subjects past
with her landscape after several minutes
subject agrees to continue communication
to the subject is muted and conversation
of control making commentary about
subjects jittery attitude makeup audio
for one and a half minutes communication
is restored and subject reaches bottom
of Stan
the seller of the farmhouse is
unremarkable and typical several wooden
shelves line the far wall containing
unidentified canned substances broken
light fixtures swayed gently from the
support beams cameras panned across the
basement slowly no evidence of
footprints are visible and the basement
can be assumed to have been abandoned
for some time subject begins to comment
about a stench as subject pans the area
a metal hatch is visible into the ground
similar to a bulkhead on a submarine
with a turn handle subject remarks that
the smell is at its worst around the
hatch and the dirt around the hatch is
noted as being clumped and clay like the
handle of the hatches old and the paint
is chipped subject coerced into touching
the handle which when fully turned opens
the hatch subject begins coughing at the
release of assumed old stale air when
camera is tilted to view down the hatch
it is a white concrete tunnel similar to
the one found in the blue experiment but
in much better condition subject asked
to descend ladder and closed hatch
behind her after some convincing subject
agrees to descend but does not close the
hatch overlooked concerns about severing
the pulley return system in doing so are
acknowledged descent down the ladder and
trip to the farmhouse has consumed
approximately 53 meters of cable when
bottom is reached inside of the hatch
appears to be a bunker ill-suited to
long term usage it is spacious about
half the size of the actual cellar
itself containing three bunks one for a
couple and two for single-use several
boxes of food similar to those found
during blue marked as cereal fill a
waste container near the hatch bottom on
the beds are two skeletons and on the
floor is a third lying next to which is
a simple six-shooter revolver containing
no ammunition three spent case
are across the floor near the gun on the
other side of the skeleton is a bound
book in good condition this is retrieved
and placed into a field kit container
upon request the gun is left alone per
request from control subject examines
more of the bunker focusing on a desk
where a newspaper has been cut and is in
good condition the clipped articles are
recovered using a field kit container
little else of interest to be brought
back is in the bunker as the cameras
panned around trash bags containing
clothing a few children's toys
resembling popular 1950s era products
are lined against the wall subject is
requested to leave the bunker and then
sharply asked to wait by a control
technician who directs the camera view
to an area near the exiting doorway to
the hatch closer inspection a subject
moves in finds that a small area has
been fitted with what appears to be an
Ethernet jack
the cover of which has been forced
slightly away from the wall by a strange
amber-like substance subject refuses to
touch or collect a sample commenting
that it stinks so bad if they want it
they can come and get it themselves
controller declines and the subject
leaves the bunker a subject grips ladder
to leave the camera pans up for a moment
and at the top of the tunnel a humanoid
figure is seen peering down control asks
subject to confirm figure subject states
nothing is up there and begins to climb
figure draws out of camera view after
first rung is touched by subject who
ascends without incident at the top of
the tunnel no other life is seen nothing
has been disturbed subject insists
nothing was there and closes the hatch
then immediately vomits subject coughs
and uses the supplied water bottle to
gargle then freezes and asks if control
is hearing that control reports no audio
subject approaches cellar hatch
cautiously but the firearm drawn
and lifts her head just enough so camera
can view outside area in the distance
approximately 700 meters from farm two
massive humanoid beings are crawling
across the landscape the entities do not
notice the subject who remains quiet but
who's drawn side arm is visibly
trembling subject requested to remain
still and silent as beings move
they are featureless facing at an angle
moving across the field of vision so the
faces are only visible for a few moments
during this time it is clear they have
no facial features the arms they used to
drag themselves are short at times and
long at others stretching out to varying
lengths each time they move there is no
rear area to the beings all bodily
design appears to end at the torso the
two creatures take approximately ten
minutes to disappear into the distance
before the subject begins to panic and
begs to return requests declined subject
instructed to enter the home from the
cellar and not to leave the home under
any circumstances first floor is entered
through a hatch in the ceiling floor
that opens with rusty creaks that caused
subject to pause for 37 seconds before
continuing upward and entering a kitchen
a heavy layer of dust coats all items in
the kitchen the refrigerator is left
open all food is spoiled adjacent the
kitchen is a living area that subject
enters slowly there is a recliner a
couch a television of all 1950 style
design in the recliner is a laptop whose
case resembles a 1950s decor and is
coated and heavy dust opening the laptop
reveals the last moments of its
operating system faithful OS leaving a
standby mode and immediately shutting
off laptop has no external power source
and will not power back on
when asked to recover the laptop it
brings the cushion of the recliner with
it the two stuck together subject
advised to leave the laptop where it is
the inside door leaving the home is
nailed shut
with thick wood planks no attempt made
to interact with these camera view pants
to a staircase leading upstairs subject
descends the stairs without being asked
and the stairs remain silent to control
surprised when subject reaches top of
the stairs a hallway with two doors is
viewed one on each side at the end of
the hall a dumbwaiter is inlaid into the
wall subject opens door on left on her
own which opens to a master bedroom the
bed is neatly made but the Wardrobe next
to it is thrown open and close our
everywhere on the floor subject finds
laid out on the bed several pieces of
jewelry and is informed to leave them
subject begins to protest then comments
they stink and leaves them alone
promptly leaving the room subject is
asked to open second door the second
door opens and gives a view of a shared
children's bedroom obviously boy and
girl given the types of toys and clothes
scattered on the floor there is also a
window which subject approaches and
wipes with a curtain to clear dust
subject requested to move camera to
window and does so the farmland is
visible approximately 40 kilometres from
it at best guess a city as the camera
starts to draw back it pans down it
films the area around the house
approximately 300 figures similar to
those from the footage captured during
blue tests are visible around the home
all staring up the subject asked to
confirm figures but states nothing is
there
subject requested to return and quickly
agrees egress from the house is
uneventful pulley system shows no
erratic behavior as subject returns to
point of pulley wires origin a loud
groaning noise causes the picture to
reverberate technicians that control
report they were also able to hear the
noise and experience the vibration
subject returns through
origin without investigation and mirror
returns to reflective surface SCP 93
relinquished video ends return newspaper
fragments filed as next we are moving on
to mirror test three color violet
subject is d8 four nine three zero male
21 years of age average physique
subjects background shows instance of
second-degree murder of a police officer
during a drug bust
normally this crime while severe would
not qualify a person for a sentence that
would end up with us but the murder of
the officer was especially brutal an
excessive violence was used this subject
was uncooperative and had to be reminded
that his cooperation would only benefit
him subject entered the provided mirror
while holding a CP 93 which emitted a
violet color outside technicians
observed that the mirror retained a true
reflection until subject had completely
passed into it at which time the view
changed to a cityscape urban lightly
tinged in purple similar to the first
test video feed follows an attached
media by now you know the drill camera
flickers to life and pans around the
area subject is in what appears to be a
modern downtown district similar to a
city like New York the streets are
mostly bare except for a few cars of
unknown make or model these cars look
highly advanced and streamlined subject
attempts to look into car windows
without being instructed but backs away
remarking there is a rank ass stank
coming from the areas around most of
them subject is persuaded to move closer
to one car and does so with coughing
wiping off a window which is covered in
dirt the inside of the car appears to be
completely filled with a strange brown
matter there was nothing at all visible
other than
Brown matter the other two cars produce
the same results however a fourth
vehicle seems more recent than the
others and the insides are immaculate
the doors to this vehicle are also
unlocked and the subject gets quickly
inside and shuts the doors
subject is chastised for his behavior by
control who reminds him his life line is
nothing more than a cable which is
sturdy enough that closing a car door
does not injured but they cannot recover
a person in motion subject argues with
control over this issue and pans the
camera across the dashboard pointing out
he couldn't drive away even if he tried
the dashboard is void of any
recognizable controls no ignition no
steering it has several small blank
screens that are theorized to be a GPS
system subject remains in the car while
control discusses how to proceed since
the cityscape is far larger than the
previous test destinations control
debates this issue while subject stares
around the cityscape from the car during
one pan a face is clearly seen staring
into the car eyes watching the subject
however this was not noticed until post
test footage review subject made no
comment regarding this entity at any
point control shortly after and forms
the subject to remain where he is and an
escort team is dispatched through the
mirror to join him a team of four armed
personnel is sent through the mirror and
precedes the subjects location subject
is instructed to remove his harness
which is recovered this subjects video
feed then ends and is replaced by a
wireless unit by the escort team the
video quality on this unit is subject to
more interference but in order to mark
the mirror exit a receiver system is
placed through the mirror subject leaves
the car and now travels with the escort
team given the myriad of possible
options they are instructed to simply
move to the closest building and attempt
to enter it
this building has etched glass doors
bearing the name
xD a research partners incorporated and
the doors are ajar a magnetic lock
system is present but it's lost power
team enters the building and main lobby
this area resembles a stereotypical
corporate Lobby there is a c-shaped
receptionist desk with a chair pushed
far from it as if it was left in a hurry
a PC terminal is at the desk as well
team approaches the desk and the camera
bearer is instructed to examine the PC
the unit does appear to have power and
faithful OS appears on the screen
requesting a login and password a
keyboard is present but is remarkably
slim but touch sensitive Keys rather
than press down keys after one failed
attempt the lock screen replies that
maximum attempts have been exceeded and
the PC turns off no actual tower or
power button can be located so team
moves forward behind the reception desk
or two elevators one to the left and one
to the right with similar touch sense
keys the elevator on the left is broken
the door opened and the shaft empty the
elevator on the right appears to be
functional and has power without a clear
destination the team is instructed to
proceed to the highest floor to get a
lay of the city all floors appear to be
accessible with the highest being 114 in
reality 112 as 13 and 113 are missing
from the keypad journey up the elevator
is uneventful during this time the
elevator does appear to take longer as
it passes by 13 and then 113 suggesting
that the entire floor was built and
nothing put on it at 114 the doors open
and the team enters a large lounge type
area there are many couches with dust on
them
a widescreen apparently LCD TV of
approximately 60 plus inches in size
dominates the wall in front of them with
no power a series of windows are open
allowing in sunlight at the far end to
which the team proceeds and angles the
camera outside the view of the city is
astonishing this building is one of the
tallest visible but certainly not alone
in its stature the city below is gray
and silent no evidence of life at this
altitude some buildings in the city have
a strange brown growth that appears to
have been splashed against them as if a
gelatinous mass was flung and then
seeked down before hardly other
buildings have floors where the glass
has been shattered and the same brown
substance seeping out the edges one
member of the team calls the camera
bearer to the windows on the other side
from the other side of the building city
edges can be seen attention is pointed
towards an expressway that encircles the
city upon which crawls another of the
large half-body humanoids dragging
itself with its elastic arms as
witnessed in previous tests it travels
the highway then moves out of sight the
team returns to the elevator and notes
that a button has already been activated
on floor 74 no one has approached the
elevator so the team agrees to travel to
this floor on the 74th floor the doors
open and reveal a waiting area to what
appears to be a doctor's office at the
reception desk there is a sign-in sheet
with a series of names and dates the
dates on the sign-in sheet all carry the
year 1953 a PC at the receptionist area
is on and functioning at a user desktop
the background for the PC is a large set
of praying hands with the word faithful
OS underneath them on the desktop are a
series of folders with the years on that
containing files that when clicked using
the center button of the mouse open to a
word viewer all files appear to be
appointment information on the desk is a
notepad titled from the desk of dr.
burrows iski blest purification Asst
the door to the doctor's area is
sketched with same name and title as
well as a crucifix opening this door
leads to a white dust free
hallway that has to examination rooms
and a key coded door at the end the
examination rooms are unremarkable and
typical of any doctor's office all
medical cabinets are empty a small
amount of c-4 is placed at the lock to
the key coded door at the request of
control and then blown forcing the door
open the area it opens into is much
larger than the reception area itself
and seems to contain a series of large
containment capsules there are a total
of six of these capsules two are broken
and a brownish amber material coats the
floor coming from them one is empty the
last three have nude humans floating in
them with breathing masks attached to
the front of these tubes are medical
charts showing vital signs and
conditions for symptoms the charts
explained in somewhat awkward English
ailments that seemed more like flaws of
personality or character or just
incidents that have occurred with the
patient control asks for a zoom of one
of the patient pages on the chart after
focusing it reads citizen Jennifer
Majorca that did suffer a lapse of the
heart it did lead to her to lay with her
neighbor twice upon nights of her
husband's departure from their home
patient did submit herself into the
Lord's and our hands for cleansing of
mind and body prayer administered by hi
father who a locket and patients
submitted to a three day period in the
Lourdes tears the cleanser system then
released in good spirits the topmost
page reads citizen imperious Farah Phan
struck out at a high father during
sermon blaspheming that the Lord's tears
did turn his daughter to be unright in
mind and heart thusly laying blame for
her [ __ ] activities at the feet of
the high father and his blessing with no
proof of these blasphemies the forgiving
judge and the punishing judge did agree
that Alby Ria's Farfan should bathe in
the Lord's tears himself for a week to
be cleansed of mind and soul thus to
prove his daughter's ways our fault not
of the father's hands and to give him
peace of self subject who has been
travelling quietly with the escort team
now begins to panic the camera pans to
focus on him and he is surrounded by
Anthony similar to those witnessed in
the first two tests escort team reports
in that subject is having a panic attack
but control requests them to stand still
and wait subject screams at the entities
which are denied to exist by team
commander stating subject is alone in
the corner control requests that one
team member be dispatched to approach
and recover the subject the escort team
member approaches the subject as ordered
on the video the figures part to make a
pathway for the approaching member who
lifts subject to his feet and brings him
out of the corner figures on the video
are seen closing ranks to close the path
subject is lifted to his feet by an
armed and escorted through the figures
that closed their ranks when the subject
is moved they remain steadfastly staring
at the subject no matter where he moves
to control requests the team returned
now team turns to leave before leaving a
team member mentioned something noticed
at the reception desk a binder labelled
the Lord's tears Cantrell requests
binder be returned as well and is stowed
in two subjects field kit the team
returns to the elevator and returns to
the ground floor upon leaving the
building subject points down the street
toward direction of entry point the
camera pans to a section of raised
Expressway across which one of the large
torsos is crawling slowly the entity
turns its featureless head to look at
the escort team raises its head to the
sky and emits a bellowing sound team
leader issues the order to move heading
for the spot marked by the wireless
video receiver the creature on the
expressway extends an arm down that
stretches to touch the ground before
camera moves to the port all team
members say one move through the entry
point subject moves through entry point
and mirror returns to reflective surface
SCP 93 is dropped by subject who panics
and tries to fight his way out of the
room subject is terminated by leader
after he draws the field kit pistol Team
Leader requests portal be reopened but
it takes several minutes to find someone
who can hold a CP 93 and generate a
similar color when a matching color is
displayed and applied to the mirror the
video receiver is visible and all
individuals report a horrific smell team
leader moves through the entryway with
the control person the uniform and
possessions of the escort team member
who was left behind are present and
recovered but the member himself is
nowhere to be seen and does not respond
to shouts member assumed killed in
action and wireless receiver recovered
control and escort returned through
entry point and Merritt returns to
reflective surface later review of the
recovered camera shows escort members
grasping at the air where the entry
point should be and then turning to look
up at the oversized
torso a brown gel seems to drip off the
creature as it moves that disappears
shortly after being dislodged as if
evaporating several shots are fired at
the creatures face with the automatic
weapon carried but the land in the face
of the creature causing a spray of less
viscous brown liquid to pour forth from
the wounds
screams obscenities as the face of the
creature descends upon him and the
camera is pushed to the ground camera
feed remains dark for approximately 65
seconds before light comes back and the
camera films the creature crawling back
to the expressway and pulling itself
onto it and then crawling in the
direction it was originally headed
believed to have been absorbed by the
creature and perhaps digested this may
have been an example of how these
unknown entities feed by direct contact
with living material further study is
recommended to be avoided on this issue
returned ledger file this okay this is
mirror test for color yellow d-class
subjects no longer authorized for
testing testing focus has been shifted
to data collection after analyzing the
articles brought back from the previous
three tests to better understand the
fate of the world accessed by a CP 93
and determine if safeguards or practices
are required for our own world analysis
of the brown fluid and the clothing of
the lost escort team members has been
filed with other recovered articles
doctor has volunteered for this test as
out of the possible candidates he was
able to cause SCP 93 to undergo a new
color change there was no evidence of
dr. background of any illegal or
criminal behavior nor of any
psychological problems when presented to
the mirror the view changed to that of a
cubical office environment for this test
dr opted to use the wireless video
system and forego the pulley return
system stating he was confident he would
be safe as none of the torso creatures
have been witnessed within a building
where the mayor's destination showed
video feed commences after doctor has
crossed the mirror as with prior tests
SCP 93 s current color yellow tinges all
video material camera flickers to life
and pans across a series of plain white
cubicle constructs approximately 30 are
visible at the far end from the point of
entry is an office module built into the
wall with frosted glass walls and a
glass door doctor approaches this door
and investigates the etched writing on
it senior manager Stanley milliwatts the
door is unlocked doctor enters the
office and examines the desk a coffee
cup is on the desk a dark brown stain
covering half of the inside as the
liquid evaporated there is a doughnut on
a plate which dr. picks up and lobs at a
wall
impact it thumps like a rock and falls a
file cabinet in the corner of the room
drawers doctor the tension and he goes
through each shelf one at a time
stopping in the second drawer and taking
out a file then going back to the first
and taking out to others continuing to
the third and fourth drawers he
withdraws four additional files and
spreads them all out on the desk the
files are blue filing folders he points
with his finger and camera at a symbol
on each of praying hands stating aloud
for the camera that all other files are
stored in yellow folders the blue
folders are placed in his field kit
camera attention has turned to the PC on
the desk that is logged in and
functional dr. comments aloud wondering
where these devices are getting their
power from as he has noticed no power
outlets this pcs desktop contains the
logo of faithful OS and even has sounds
clicks of the mouse followed by soft him
like hums and opening of icons followed
by angelic bells the PC fails to yield
any useful information to dr. who
abandons it and leaves the office
approaching the other end of the office
dr. presses a button on the wall for the
elevator and enters finding he is on the
34th floor of a building having an
unusual number scheme the keypad layout
goes from minus 115 to 115 and includes
all floors before pressing a floor
button doctor requests that the wireless
video transponder be moved to the
elevator and replaced with a
construction cone to mark the entry
point a second transponder unit is
placed outside the elevator and control
is instructed to recover the second unit
and seal the test chamber should
something happen to
then when all is arranged he presses the
button for floor - 115 the descent down
the elevator is long consuming 15
minutes during this time the camera
experiences one malfunction where the
image jerks and turns to snow restoring
to show 14 other figures in the elevator
with dr. as the video pans around all of
whom move as he moves to allow him space
they remain for 35 seconds and then the
camera flickers to snow and returns dr.
now alone in the elevator dancing as is
assumed by the Ducks and sways of the
video feed
dr. pauses to comment on a rising stench
coming from below at this point the
elevator has reached floor - 108 dr.
presses - 110 to interrupt the descent
down and exits when that floor is
reached the elevator doors open to an
enclosed observation deck with several
pcs and chairs all pcs appear to have
power the ceiling - this deck is also
glass and above it another deck is
visible doctor approaches the monitoring
stations and checks one of the PC
screens on the screen is the faithful OS
logo and a video feed toggling between
four different views the first view is a
room of tubes similar to those found in
tests violet which number in the
thousands the second view is a closer up
view of these tubes as a camera glides
in front of each to monitor the contents
all tubes the camera passes by are
broken the third view is facing the
opposite direction as a camera glides
vertically checking each observation
station a total of ten can be counted
and a doctor is visible as the camera
passes by his own station looking up a
hovering camera unit with no visible
means of propulsion glides up past him
the fourth view shows the ground floor
below the observation deck where a
single astonishingly large torso is
crawling in circles bumping into walls
and changing directions
from the camera feed to the creatures
estimated size is six stories returning
attention to the contents of the PC dr.
gears moves the video log aside to see a
simple text editor that was hidden
behind it a printout of this text was
recovered and filed in the field kit the
printout directed dr. to a safe on floor
54 had provided a combination doctor
leaves the observation deck and proceeds
to 54 without event arriving on a
cubicle office floor he proceeds to the
desk mentioned in the document and found
a safe in beneath a desk undisturbed the
combination provided opens the safe and
reveals a notebook filed in the field
kit and a peculiar revolver that has
been returned as in addition to the 24
rounds of ammunition found with it
doctor proceeds back to the elevator
without event and returns 234 given the
sheer number of floors available to
explore and the vital information
obtained from the observation deck the
test is considered over and the
equipment retrieved before returning
through the entry point doctor
investigates a terminal nearby that has
power and finds it shows the exact same
screen as the one on -1 10 shows it is
theorized that the author of the note
installed a networked virus to propagate
through the building so any PC on that
network would be found and the
information discovered dr. returns
through the entry point and the mirror
returns to a reflective surface all
materials filed with other SCP 93
recovered materials analysis of and the
ammunition for it postponed for reason
that it would require deconstruction of
one of the rounds and they may be
beneficial until testing of SCP 93 is
resolved video ends
and finally mirror test five color red
SCP 93 distributed amongst staff until a
new color could be generated by contact
with it service technician was able to
cause SCP 93 to take on a fierce red hue
and glow much brighter than the objects
normal color agreed to assist with a
test of SCP 93 per doctor request given
to technician for use in this test when
applied to the mirror for the test SCP
93 generates an unknown environment no
color change appears present on the
displayed destination which is comprised
of redstone work technician enters the
mirror and the video capture begins
video flickers to life and technician
known hereafter as subject is viewing a
large cylindrical pillar that is
rotating on its own object is of unknown
height and appears to be 1.8 meters in
width holes are distributed throughout
the object at seemingly random intervals
on occasion a beam of white light is
emitted from these holes turning up the
camera finds that the beams are
connected to a multitude of objects
similar to SCP 93 that are part of the
rooms wall the room turns out to be
cylindrical in shape with countless
copies of SCP 93 subject turns back to
entry point and finds it is a section of
the wall that is missing it's copy of
SCP 93 presumably the one carried with
subject other sections of the wall on
inspection are also found to be missing
there copies leading to speculation that
this may be some sort of central array
the subject finds a ladder in the floor
while examining the room and proceeds
down it and controls requests the ladder
exits into a large clean room full of
computer equipment that appears
antiquated compared to previously
encountered equipment large computers
running on a reel to reels are clicking
and spinning at various locations a
light bulb of unknown meaning turns on
for 10 seconds then turns off a large
CRT monitor is displaying single words
in 8
at roughly five second intervals while
observed the words clean unclean clean
clean lost unclean flash on the screen
proceeding through the room it ends in a
large glass window as another
observation deck this deck looks out
over another series of tubes as
witnessed before but far fewer and
filled with blue liquid what appears to
be electrical current dances over many
of the tubes at erratic intervals at
least five tubes at first glance are
empty and broken the observation window
a keyboard is present on a pedestal
awaiting a selection to be made the
options available on the screen are tube
status which waits for numerical input
reports situation X 5 for nine situation
X 5 5 0 evacuation log [ __ ] agent
report and facility fire plan the rest
of this video was expunged all
selections that generated text were
transcribed by subject and verified by a
control member who passed them through
the portal to recover them this process
took approximately two hours and video
feed was deleted to condense this report
recorded documents or file that video
interrupted control lost contact with
the subject approximately 30 minutes
after departure of control tech subject
was asked to remain an area and observe
the machinery and the containment room
and make observations for debriefing the
SCP 93 mirror portal returned to a
reflective surface prematurely and all
video contact with the subject was lost
the control was unable to re-establish
due to SCP 93 being across the mirror a
time lapse of 1 minute and 48 seconds
was recorded before a mirror portal
re-established itself and subject
returned through the portal subject
appeared to be in good health and
condition despite the time loss but
spoke little
during immediate debriefing subject
under when sudden convulsions and
medical staff was alerted while
attempting to subdue subject he
displayed enhanced strength and youth to
shoot one of the debriefing staff
killing them guards shot the subject
once with a sidearm in the heart and
once in the chest but the subject did
not fall all staff evacuated the room
and a second shot was fired by subject
which missed a more heavily armed team
entered the debriefing room and used
automatic weapons to dispatch the
subject reports confirm that subject did
not bleed when shot but instead leaked a
green brown substance that seemed to be
a mix of solution observed in some
containment tubes and the material
recovered during test three all further
SCP 93 tests have been discontinued
while review of materials recovered is
in effect a secondary tape recording
device was found to have activated in
the field kit after loss of video feed
and its contents have been filed with
other recovered materials all recovered
materials from sa p90 3 testing are
level 4 classification
release must be approved by no fewer
than two level 4 personnel staff with
acceptable clearance please sign in with
doctor for access to the materials
recovered from SCP 93 tests well that's
it thanks very much for listening
everyone hopefully I'll see you all soon
you're all dismissed thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you